[Applause]
thank you ladies and gentlemen thank you
all very much for coming out tonight
can everybody hear okay yeah okay
especially happy that so many fart ik
Jews from New York and are in Orlando
have chosen to come in and from
elsewhere around the country community
and that from Orlando with the Institute
for verdict advancement and the Carroll
bat three who is an Iraqi Jewish leader
from New York and many others my book
banking on Baghdad was released a few
weeks ago and already it has struck a
chord the court that I would like to
discuss with you tonight involves the
far hood which is the Forgotten pogrom
against Iraqi Jews now it'll be easy to
just described violence and the
persecution that Iraqi Jews experienced
at the hand of their government as part
of a Nazi alliance but I'm going to do
more I'm going to explain how this and
this anti Iraqi Jewish feeling
percolated throughout the decades and
try to explain where the anguish of the
Iraqi Jews fits in to the overall Middle
East problem that we have and the
because the Iraqi Jews were put in the
middle of this and of course the Jewish
communities in the middle of this today
and it's going to start decades before
the far hood in 1941 first of course I'd
like to orient you that as you know Iraq
was originally in Mesopotamia this was
the V shaped region beat
between the two rivers it was originally
not in Iraqi it was originally not an
Arab or an Islamic country it was
originally Eurasian Eurasian more
closely in in ethnic makeup to the
caucuses to Turkey to Persia and in the
seventh century AD it was part of the
Islamic conquest and became arabised and
subsumed by an Islamic population
principally originally through two
cities in the Java and Kufa and then
later on it it it it acquired its a
fundamental Arab character many
individuals like to talk about three
basic parts of Iraq the Kurdish Islamic
portion in the third half of the in the
third section of the nation up at the
top in Mosul the Sunni area in the
middle of Baghdad and the Shia in the
southern section of Basra button point
effect that oversimplification over
overlooks the many ethnic groups which
were part of Mesopotamia and this
includes Assyrians in this includes
Armenians in Chaldeans and of course
many Jews who trace their history back
2600 years some almost a thousand years
before Islam ever came to mess with
Mesopotamia now I have explained to you
that by the seventh century that
Mesopotamia was a in an Islamic nation
it was fundamentally Islamic with all
these minority groups in it and I'd like
to skip ahead further now to some 500
years before World War 2 and 500 years
before World War two the Ottomans came
in
to the realm and ruled and as most of
you know the three basic provinces of
potamia that's Mosul in the north and
Baghdad in the center in Basra in the
south were neglected they were exploited
they were barren they were desolate and
not of a lot of interest to the Sultan
who was in Istanbul very far away I'd
like to skip further now to 1859 1859
Titusville New York
excuse me Titusville Pennsylvania and in
1859 commercial oil was discovered when
I say commercial oil we all know that
oil is as old as civilization oil goes
all the way back some 60,000 years - to
the caves of South Africa where it's
found as a sealant as a medication as a
lubricant as an ingredient for arts but
commercial oil the type of oil that was
drilled and pumped out in an industrial
process distributed in a commercial
process and used for the internal
combustion machine this was discovered
in 1859 in Titusville Pennsylvania and I
will tell you it's almost a half a
century before commercial oil is
discovered in the in the middle east now
a little bit after 1859 there was a
brilliant visionary turk by the name of
MIT hat Pasha and Medhat Pasha hoped to
bring reform to the Ottoman Empire he
hoped to bring the types of governmental
structures and individual rights that
were commonly known in Europe he tried
to bring this in to the Ottoman Empire
which stretched across three continents
from Africa to Asia to East Europe and
of course the bridge Aires the Middle
East in between and mid hot
Hacha introduced a brilliant
constitution much better than much more
egalitarian than the ones that the
Americans created in the 1790s it called
for individual rights freedom of
religion freedom of press and all this
was thought to be very very threatening
to the Sultan and so just it was about
to be implemented the Sultan had mid hat
pasha assassinated and i call that the
first last and best chance for peace and
democracy in the Middle East however one
of the reforms that was already
instituted in the Ottoman Empire before
his death was individual land reform and
this is important to understand because
all of this is going to tie right into
1941 into the fire hood and to a certain
extent into what we see on our
television sets each night land reform
allowed individuals to register the land
so that everything wasn't owned by the
Sultan the individual could also rent
owned some land and have a part in his
nation well in the 1890s the Sultan was
informed by a geologist that though that
of that the richest oil deposits
anywhere in the world probably were
under Mesopotamia especially in the
north and so the Sultan decided to
exercise his right as a citizen and he
registered all of Mesopotamia as his
personal private property paid all his
fees got all his stamps registered in
the in in the courts and now he owned
all the land privately not publicly but
privately
now the Deutsche Bank at about that time
was building a railway in this story
Bank railway was going to be called the
Berlin to Baghdad railroad and they gave
the Deutsche Bank and the Berlin to
Baghdad railway oil rights on either
side of the track and event
this was expanded to all of Mesopotamia
and eventually this private deal between
the Sultan's personal corporation if you
will called the Privy Purse and the
Deutsche Bank was elevated to an
international agreement to international
law through the bag de Roop Baghdad
railway Treaty of 1903 now around 1904
the the British principally through
Winston Churchill decided that this
great war was coming this was the war to
settle what would become of the can
everyone here okay this was the war to
discover what would what would become of
the so-called Eastern provinces the
Asian provinces of the Ottoman Empire
once the so called sick man of Europe
the Ottoman Empire dissolved well
Winston Churchill decided that the
British Navy could no longer run on coal
it had to become faster it had to become
more maneuverable it needed oil and as
they said at the time oil don't grow in
Great Britain so where did they get the
oil the only place they could get the
oil as far as they were concerned was
Iraq the anglo-persian oil company had
all had already sealed a deal for a
concession with the Shah of Iran and it
was the British idea to expand this
concession to both sides of the Zagros
Mountains so that the oil that might
come out of the ground remember oil is
still not drilled yet the all that might
come out of the ground would all belong
to Great Britain whether words on the
Persian side or whether it was on the
Mesopotamian side well the turret while
the the Ottoman Sultan whose name was
Abdul the damned the Sultan that was his
name
the Sultan said I've got to deal with
with the Germans and the British said
break it and they put pressure on the
Sultan why because Ottoman Turkey the
Ottoman Empire
was bankrupt and all the liens were held
through the public debt administration
by the Bank of England and the Ottoman
could not raise taxes could not collect
duties and and fees without the express
permission of the governor of the bank
of of England so eventually after some
four more years of baksheesh and trading
and upping the ante and meanwhile the
undrilled oil is getting more valuable
as the longer it stays in the ground
about 1908 in April the Sultan is ready
to sign on the dotted line and to to
give the oil to the British except on
the day he's ready to sign the palace is
surrounded the young turks staged their
revolution and he never gets to actually
sign the young turks seize the oil
concession no-one's got it now the
British say it belongs to us the assault
had intended to give it to us the
Deutsche Bank says no it's ours it was
taken from us and if anyone tries to
grab it we are gonna sue meanwhile the
young turks discover that they aren't
allowed to grab this oil because it's
private property and it's subject to
international law through the bag date
through through the Baghdad railway
treaty by the time the pressure is
continued to mount and by this in and by
this by this time there's oil and Persia
been discovered in 1908 so they know
that certainly there's going to be oil
on the on the Mesopotamian side by the
time the years lapse the young turks
through a lot of manipulation and a lot
of box asian a lot of pressure finally
decided in 1914 that they're going to
give the british this oil concession
that was originally taken from the
germans and was now in a company called
turkish petroleum company which was
owned by the turkish national bank which
had nothing to do with Turkey it was a
it was a British operation the British
put pressure on the Turkish National
Bank and the Turkish petroleum company
to
merged into anglo-persian and they put
pressure on the young turks to give them
the oil and recognize it and sign on the
dotted line and then World War one
breaks out and the British say you know
that German concession that we're gonna
pay all of that money for we're gonna
take it
it's enemy property now and so
immediately from 1914 the British
invaded Mesopotamia up initially through
bow through Basra then up through to
Baghdad and when they got to Baghdad
even though their only interest was oil
of course they announced from the steps
of Baghdad our armies come not as
conquerors but as liberators
this was not stoned from the Washington
Post of three weeks ago but from this
from the Sunday Times during World War
one and the war proceeded but it stopped
the war stopped on October 31st with the
Armistice and the British had only
gotten to the doorway of Mosul and
that's where the richest oil was and so
they broke the Armistice they illegally
grabbed Mosul from the Turks that the
Turks objected even Whitehall sent
orders to retreat and evacuate but by
that time it was too late the British
occupied Mosul and they said now we can
create this nation Iraq and now this
nation will have all the oil that we
need for Britain okay so now we're
getting ready for the peace conference
except now it's time to talk to you
about the Arabs and during world and
during World War one the Arabs created
allies from the from the Arab
nationalist I'd like to give you the
background The Young Turks decided to
extend their authority over the Arabian
Peninsula and in doing so they were
going to collect the taxes from the from
the pilgrims going to Mecca and Medina
and the Sharif of Mecca Hussein and of
course the Sharif is a direct descendant
from the Prophet Muhammad and the holder
of the keys to the holy city the Sharif
of Mecca told The Young Turks you can
keep your country in Istanbul and you
can collect your taxes there but you
cannot collect taxes here in Arabia in
the holy cities this is Islam and so
there was a showdown looming and the and
the and the Sharif of Mecca sought an
ally and he found an ally to oppose the
Turks and that Ally was Great Britain
and so they're Sharif of Mecca began
lying to the British about exactly what
kind of support they would give to the
to the British in this war against the
Turks and then the Turks started to lie
to the shirt to the Sharif of Mecca
about exactly what type of recognition
they would give to the Arabs for an Arab
national state and then the French and
English started lying to each other
about how they would divide up the
Middle East and everybody was lying to
everybody and everybody knew they were
being lied to him that they were lying
and nowadays they call this diplomacy
and so everybody was able to claim
everything after the war because they
each had a piece of paper which we taken
in isolation would represent a promise
but all the promises were almost now
it's important to understand that there
was another wing of Arab nationalism
that was even more important to a
certain degree and that was the effort
by a group of Arab in of Arab
intellectuals to have a national
structure remember in the Middle East
there were no nations there were clans
there were tribes there were neglected
provinces there was a centre of
authority for from the Sultan who was
collecting the taxes but there were no
nations as we know as we know them from
the British point of view they wanted to
place a nation in there so there would
be someone to sign on the dotted line to
approve to approve the oil concessions
now let's talk about those oil
concessions that the British grabbed
anglo-persian oil company grabbed during
the war a small German oil firm called
British Petroleum and and this come and
this company British Petroleum
distributed a distributed lantern oil to
London and England and throughout the
British Isles they also seized through
the courts this leftover Turkish
petroleum asset which was the original
German concession going back to 1890s
that I told you about okay so this is
all percolating while the people in the
front office and at the top of
government are discussing what type of
Arab nation they're going to create
ultimately the Brits believed that
enough of the Arabs supported them
during World War one to justify a place
at the at the peace conference in Paris
they would have a chair right next to
France and right next to England and
they would be able to be one of the
victors they would get a nation and they
said to the Arabs what type of nation do
you want what type of national structure
do you want and the Arabs
through Faisal they're duly elected
representative stated we don't need
Palestine because Palestine is a distant
place it's swamp it's swampy and Faisal
signed the contract with high invites
Minh the president of the Zionist
Organization to say you can have
unrestricted Zionist immigration into
Palestine it's all typed out was
arranged by Lawrence of Arabia but in
Arabic handwritten in faisal x' hand at
the bottom it says you get what you want
as long as we get what we want then the
Arabs said to the British we don't want
a rack we don't need a rack we don't
need oil you need oil take a rack you
can have a rack you can run it as a
colony etc etc so what did they want
they wanted Syria they wanted Damascus
because Syria was the epicenter of Arab
nationalism Arab intellectualism and
Syria was the center of gravity of the
Islamic faith for many many centuries
the British said okay and the French
said
not okay and on 1920 and in 1920 July
24th that jihad against the West began
on that day that day exploded some two
decades later in Iraq in the Far hood
that affected the Iraqi Jewish community
and continues to explode every night in
Iraq today the jihad what caused it well
on July 24th of 1920 the League of
Nations which was created by the British
and the French announced from San Remo
the mandates that is the colonial
possessions that would arise from World
War one Britain would get Palestine the
Jews would get the long-awaited homeland
that they desired the Brits would get
Iraq and the French not the Arabs would
get Syria now on that same day July 24th
of 1920 the secret oil agreements were
leaked from San Remo these agreements
were in parallel to the national
boundaries and they percolated through
all these court orders that I've
discussed and went all the way back to
the original German concession which was
finally wound up into a structure under
international law and it provided that
Iraq would have all the would would have
all of its oil controlled by Britain
that there would be a pipeline across
Syria controlled by the French and
another pipeline going down to Haifa
controlled by the British on that same
day July 24th of 1920 designed this
conference in London created an
organization called Karen hi Assad to
collect nickels and dimes and dollars
from the Jews of the world to ultimately
purchase pursuant to international law
the lands of Palestine to create the
towns and cities and kibbutz 'im of the
future Israeli homeless
on that same day July 24th of 1920 the
French told Faisal to get the heck out
of Syria they gave him 48 hours even
though he was the elected king of the
second Syrian National Congress which
itself was a was a democratic elected
body and on that same day July 24th of
1920 some 8000 Arab warriors came out to
meet the French West of Damascus
screaming and hollering on their camels
and their horses with their rifles and
their Lance's and they were all
slaughtered and cut down by modern tanks
and machine guns and that day began a
legacy known to the Arabs is I'll knock
BA the year of the catastrophe that is
that is the year when the Arabs got
nothing and the Christian infidel that
they barely recognized as a human being
got everything including dominion over
their lands the Jews got the homeland
that they had been struggling for in
Palestine and they all got the oil and
from that moment on the Arabs have
conflated the oil the Christian European
the Jew and Palestine into one great
satan and faisal warned the peace
conference you know we're not just a
bunch of Arabs and they on camels in the
desert anymore we have modern technology
we have trains we have Telegraph's we
can move around you'll hear from us and
then the jihad exploded everywhere it
exploded in Lebanon it explodes in Syria
it explored in Iraq it exploded in
Palestine the beheadings the bus
bombings the massacres the aerial
rotelle
and everything you've seen on television
for the past year has been going on
there since the 1920s year after year
after year and it all began essentially
when this period ignited it and amongst
the many the many militants who exploded
against a British and all those allied
with the British was the mufti of
Jerusalem and the mufti of Jerusalem
helped orchestrate an incredible
anti-semitic wave and an anti Zionist
wave against the Jews of Palestine with
the bus bombings in the kid and and the
kidnappings and the murders and the
cinema bombings and ultimately the
British went to arrest him and
ultimately he slipped off from the
Temple Mount dressed as a woman
and took refuge in Lebanon in Syria skip
ahead skip ahead to the beginning of
World War 2 6 a.m. September 1st 1939
Nazi Germany launches the war and mid
hot Pasha excuse me the mufti of
Jerusalem immediately meets with
Hitler's henchmen and immediately cuts a
deal with Hitler personally to seek the
Arab nationalism that the British denied
the Arabs to wipe to help wipe out the
Jews who were in Palestine and an
Eastern Europe in exchange for Iraqi oil
mitt had the mufti of Jerusalem then
transferred his base of operations from
Lebanon and Syria into Baghdad and
worked with a fascist coup a pro-nazi
coup called the golden square to
mitigate to militate and to agitate
against the Jews and against the regent
who had been appointed
by the British to rule the country okay
now it's April of 1941 Hitler is getting
ready for operation Barbosa to invade
Russia everything in world in the World
War two is running on oil the Brits are
saying if we can only get Hitler's
trucks to drive one more kilometer the
jeeps to drive one more kilometer the
tanks one more kilometer let him use up
all of his oil then we might have a
chance at winning but if Hitler gets the
oil of Iraq how are we going to win this
war and deal that the mufti of Jerusalem
made was he would give that oil that
Hitler needed to invade Russia and the
rest of the east in exchange for the
destruction of the Jews in Palestine as
I said and their destruction in Eastern
Europe before they ever got to Palestine
and of course in Arab national states
the golden square an association with
Rashid Al Ali and the mufti of Jerusalem
launched a coup d'etat on April 1st and
within a couple of days the Regent fled
and now they were running Iraq and
offering the oil to Adolf Hitler well
the British had a base at a place called
Hibernia and they were trying to resist
the Iraqi coup Hitler sent in his best
aviators and best airplanes to bomb the
British forces there they were refueling
in in Lebanon and Syria and they were
flying over Iraq and bombing eventually
the British didn't have any forces to
commit to Iraq because everyone was
stretched so thin so they went into
Palestine and they called out the
commander of the Irgun David Rossi al
and they said if we can't kick the
pro-nazi regime out of Iraq we're going
to have to blow up the refineries blow
up the oil infrastructure
they sent him up into Iraq to seek out
the intelligence necessary to blow up
the refineries in addition to that they
went into other Palestine jails and they
formed a secret Jewish commando group
called the Palmach and they sent Moshe
Dayan and his assistant is chakra beam
and others up into Lebanon in Syria to
help destroy the refineries and
refuelling deep depots that the Germans
were using to bomb the British in Iraq
eventually a small British column was
able to rout the Iraqi forces and the
air base to British air base at ha ha
and Hibernia was able to overwhelm and
destroy the German aircraft and the the
pro-nazi coup was forced to flee on may
31st of 1941 now it's June 1st it's four
o'clock in the morning and the British
are stopped at the gates of Baghdad and
they decide they're not going to escort
the region back in because they don't
want to look like he's he is their
puppet no one is even in Baghdad to sign
the armistice because they've all fled
so the mayor walks out with a white flag
and says where do I sign and and the war
is over for the moment in that part of
Iraq now the Regent starts flying in to
Baghdad from his safe location out of
the country it's about noon at about 1
or 2 o'clock the Jews of Baghdad on
Shavuos which is a Jewish holiday as you
all know go out to meet him now who are
the Jews of Iraq or the Jews of Iraq go
back 2600 years as I said a thousand
years before Islam came they were part
of the government infrastructure
infrastructure they were running the
railroads running the Telegraph they
were the backbone of the entire
financial and banking industry they were
the Exedy exporters they were the
retailers they were among the best
educated they were so thoroughly Iraqi
that they didn't even believe that there
was a connection between them and is in
pallet Jewish Palestine there was no
Zionism in the Iraq of nine of early
1941 just as the Germans were more
German than Jewish to a large degree the
Iraqi Jews were more Iraqi than Jewish
and why not that was their homeland they
were fully as much as a quarter of
Baghdad and in prior years they're even
much more of the local population
so at this time about three o'clock in
the afternoon June 1st of 1941 the Jews
of Baghdad are returning from the
airport where they have met the Regent
and welcomed him back the Regent has not
yet had time to drive into his palace
the Brits are still on the outskirts of
town there's a power vacuum no one's
running it there's no one in authority
an Arab mob seized the Jews and
immediately sets upon them they start
murdering them and it's pretty soon the
violence spreads throughout Baghdad
people are murdered the babies are
killed in front of their parents
the girls are raped in front of their
family in front of their families the
Jewish businesses by the scores are
burned and looted one of the leading
synagogues is invaded and the Torah
defiled the Jewish homes are invaded and
burned and and the fan-in and the
families are murdered and maimed right
in their own faith in their own
households and it goes on for two days
the police joined in Baghdad is burning
only until the British finally assert
themselves
On June 2nd declare a curfew and restore
order
are the Jews tenuously reassured but for
sure on May 31st the Jews went of Iraq
went to bed anti Zionist and on June 2nd
they woke up and they were Zionists this
day was the beginning of the end of the
twenty-six hundred year existence of the
Jews of Iraq now this day has been
forgotten too many of those who have
studied the Holocaust and many of those
who have studied world World War two but
the Iraqi community has a name for this
and the word is far hood there are many
definitions some say it means riots and
some say it means thievery but the one
that I have adopted that I've heard the
most often is violent dispossession and
the persecution increased and the
exclusions increased and the boycotts
increased and little by little the Jews
were squeezed more and more out of the
place they once held in their nation of
2600 years Iraq and early March of 1951
the phones went dead in Baghdad and on
that day in secret the Iraqi government
passed law 5 which stated that any Jew
who desired to leave the country upon
expressing that desire would almost it
would immediately within some 15 days
lose their Iraqi citizenship they would
be de natura lized and the secret
regulation of law 5 regulation 12
provided that all their assets would be
seized and they would have to leave
completely penniless with the shirt on
their back and the Iraqi government said
we're sending them to Israel Israel said
we will take we will take them the Iraqi
government said we're sending them to
you at the rate of ten thousand a month
for 10 months for 12 months a hundred
and twenty thousand Israel didn't even
have a hundred and twenty thousand tents
the plan was to break the back of the
new Israeli infrastructure by sending
them thousands of penniless Iraqi Jews
at a time when Israel was already
struggling to to absorb Jews from
Eastern Europe from Poland from Yemen
from other parts of the Arab world
Ezreal was just bursting and the Iraqi
government said if you don't take him
there stateless their citizenship has
been revoked and we're gonna put them in
concentration camps so the Israelis
through the mossad created a secret
airline and the airlift started day and
nights day and night directly indirectly
through Cyprus through elsewhere through
Persia sometimes in the air and
sometimes on truck tell 120 thousand
Jews about all but about six to eleven
thousand within one year were brought
out of Iraq and eventually over the
subsequent years the remaining Jews were
taken out of Iraq or smuggled themselves
out until now there are approximately
six to perhaps two dozen Jews depending
upon who's counting left in Iraq
and there's a continuity here a very
unhappy one that the present situation
that the Jews find themselves in and the
destruction of the Iraqi Jewish presence
which was 2,600 years long all began on
one day June 1st of 1941 based upon a
jihad that started on July 24th of 1920
based upon oil that was granted to the
Germans in 1890 that the British decided
they would have to have thank you very
much
and now ladies and gentlemen I will take
questions I will ask the the rules are
very simple because we have a great
number of people here more than we were
expecting please no speeches or state or
a statement so we have enough time for
everyone so sir may know your question
that you had occurred on that day what
made that crowd suddenly well it wasn't
it was just a coincidence that all those
events culminated on July 24th of 1920
but there was no coincidence that I
discovered it because I looked for the
common connection I looked to connect
the dots I look to see what culminated
on what days and I discovered that the
culmination of all of the threads that
led to the explosion in the middle east
was on July 24th of 1920 bearing in mind
that the Jews had had a successful
existence throughout centuries in the
Ottoman Empire and and in Mesopotamia of
course there were the usual problems
that any non-muslim would have in a
state that is intolerant against
non-muslims but it started then in 1920
Carol Basra there's one other piece that
maybe doesn't come in with the oil and
that was why was this deal with fine
Weitzman I don't think it was just
because of the benevolent to the British
whining I have a Jewish homeland I think
you also want to look at why they didn't
go in in the Far during those two days I
think they were trying to also destroy
the network of Iraqi Jews that were
entrepreneurial in India Singapore Hong
Kong Surabaya Burma Shanghai and they
were trying to break down that network
that had been very very strong
entrepreneurially and they thought and
their papers in the Foreign Office that
say if all the Jews end up in Israel we
can break that Network and that's why
they didn't go in for those two days
okay the question if I understand it is
where the British not only in not also
interested
in dismantling or in interfering and sub
and so planting the Jewish mercantil
Network that was throughout India and
throughout other parts of the British
Empire the answer is yes of course that
was one of their interests but there's
no question that the British were
attempting to create the Jewish homeland
of course you should know that during
the 20s it was the British plan to
Indian Eyes Mesopotamia to Indian Eyes
Iraq they were going to bring millions
and millions of Indians and people who
are now in Pakistan into meth potamia
into Iraq to create a brand new
infrastructure a brand new commercial
Oasis if you will that would have
allowed them and only them meaning the
British and only the British to
capitalize on the cotton and all of the
other types of commodities that were in
that area and so there are many many
reasons why the British agreed to to
encourage the Jewish home in Palestine
and to to encourage the immunization of
Mesopotamia another question I think
there was also the first finance
minister of Iraq was an Iraqi Judy
Haskell Sassoon and he's the one who
negotiated the gold standard for oil and
the British didn't like being on the
gold standard for oil that's an
important point in Iraq he jus a writ
originated the gold standard for oil for
the British the British of course
through British Petroleum through
anglo-persian oil company I wish to
stretch that stressed and British
Petroleum cooperated completely with my
investigation and that was one of the
elements that the British didn't like
but I assure you the entire Iraqi
monetary system was created by Iraqi
Jews for the benefit of the Iraqi nation
and
Britany she always didn't like it
because the wreckage ooze were loyal
Iraqis and they worked very very hard
the question I saw yes go go go ahead
please how long did it take me to write
the book well my family doesn't want me
to answer that because it was day and
night for approximately seven months of
course I was here a year ago for my last
book a war against a week but I was
running a team of some 30 researchers in
a hundred and ten archives including
access to the archives of anglo-persian
oil company anglo-iraqi oil Turkish
petroleum Anglo Iranian petroleum the we
had access to the Hagen arc archives in
Israel the Foreign Office in Great
Britain and the reason we were able to
write the book so quickly is because I
used a great deal of technology even
though you weren't allowed to use the
telephones in the archives we were text
messaging each other on the Nokia's and
on our cell phones across the ocean with
the information that we found we were
scanning documents putting them up on
private websites and we were able to
move a lot faster than I could have when
I did war against a week which took a
year and a half and IBM the Holocaust
which took two years and a half and
transfer agreement which took five years
which had of course be typed 40 times
there were no computers sir 600 years
simplification is inevitable so
therefore I'd like to take two issues
with you there are two things that you
stated one with regard to June 2nd that
the Jews of Iraq went and went to sleep
and designers woke up as pros honest the
fact of the matter is immediately after
the fur hood the use of Iraq have had
the most wonderful you know the most
wonderful economic prospects
in their history the issue of Zionism
did not come up until after the
partition of Palestine in 1947 and the
increasing hostility toward them by the
by the Iraqis and in fact the letter we
tried to turn that into a question other
question is did the question of Zionism
creep into the Iraqi community
immediately after June 2nd or was it
really after 1947 of course the answer
is that the Iraqi community absolutely
did not wish to accept the fact that it
that it was seeing the end of its long
existence in Iraq it held on to its
loyal Iraqi nature I find it completely
parallel to that which most people have
discovered in Germany where the German
Jews just held on to the very last
minute even at the very end even in 1944
and 1945 they didn't want to go to
Palestine they didn't want to leave
their native Germany and of course it
was the youngest within the Iraqi Jewish
community it was the young it was the
young people who tried to explain to to
to their parents that the time had come
they worked in secret they worked in
secret you know Herzl said prisoners old
prisoners leave their cells only
reluctantly and it was not an
instantaneous awakening there was a
slumber an important fact it took some
time but it was long before the end of
World War two
that designed it the thought of Zionism
began to spread throughout Iraq I must
also say to you I must also say that in
May of 1945 World War two ended the Nazi
regime stopped but the Nazi regime but
the Nazi program did not stop in the
Arab world and the concept of
identifying
the Jews boycotting the Jews excluding
them from the economic mainstream
seizing their assets persecuting them
this continued and in 1947 when the Arab
League surrounded Israel they did not
say we're going to liberate our brethren
they did not say we're going to kick the
Jews out of Palestine they said we're
going to exterminate the Jews once and
for all and of course the that did not
occur and the only country that did not
sign the ceasefire was Iraq which never
signed the ceasefire another question
another question that you answered yes
in the preface to your book when you
discuss sources you you mentioned how
most everybody was cooperative and
making files and source information
available except for and you point to
IBM in Halliburton I was curious as to
what sort of information you were hoping
to get from them and what historically
was their involvement in all of this
well the Halliburton information we were
looking at me first of all half the
material that I went after never made it
into the book because it would take a
book of some 20 volumes to cover 7,000
years of history I've devoted a great
deal of time and research to ain't to
ancient Mesopotamia to the Mongols to
the Ottoman Empire etc and that there
was a time when we were investigating
the activities of Halliburton during
Gulf War engulfed to that material never
made it into the book in part because we
had to we didn't have as much space as
we wanted to and also I did not want
this book to be in any way political I
did not want this book in any way to be
hooked to the current times five years
in 10 years in 20 years from now people
may wonder who Halliburton is all of my
books are permanent there are books on
in the back there they were written more
than 20 years ago which are still
relevant today
so that's on Halliburton with regard to
IBM I specifically asked for them to
open up their files with regard to the
Armenians in 1915 and 1917 to find out
the statistical services that they were
providing to the Turks and they refused
and IBM has of course refused to open up
its archives to anyone to investigate
its act its activities with those types
of programs yes ma'am comment regarding
your numbers I Jewish US Army chaplain
has reported just in Baghdad far more
than just two dozen Jews albeit they
don't know too much about Judaism
anymore but it's still small number you
you described here a long period of
British interest in the oil particularly
and various activities and dungeons I'm
getting there one second they've done
through through these years what do you
think if any what hand does the British
oil interest and intelligence interest
had in creating the situation we now
have in Iraq well first of all as to
whether there are six Jews left in Iraq
or whether there's two dozen I think
that perhaps the most authoritative one
of the most authoritative people in the
United States is seated in this audience
now who has just recently done a survey
and so while it may be sixth and it may
be two dozen I doubt if it's it's about
two dozen so it's not more than that I
and she has done specific surveys for
both the government and the for the
Jewish community now as far as what the
British intelligent rest's have
participated and contributed to the
current mess I think that for some 90
years the West the United States France
England have sent their best militaries
their best surrogate corporations their
best diplomats
a deeper and deeper into Iraq and into
the quagmire of Iraq to get the oil you
know in 1917 the American Petroleum
Institute sent a secret memo to the
Wilson administration in 1917 and they
said we've only got 40 more years of oil
left in this country in this country and
unless we get it from Iraq we're out of
oil now what's in now what's interesting
is the the Americans never declared war
on Turkey and the Americans were not
part of the League of Nations because of
course Congress never ratified the
treaty so how was the United States
going to get its Iraqi oil well France
and England were going to divide this up
and in addition to creating a nation
where never existed so someone could
sign on the dotted line they also wanted
to instill democracy which is a word
that's been used for many decades there
so it'd be a quite an environment for
the oil to flow and the United States
said did you say democracy democracy
means you can't discriminate against our
oil companies and so we adopted what is
known as the open door policy meaning
the door had to remain open for Iraqi
oil to companies from other nations once
the United States got in the door was
allowed to shut of course and so in 1927
oil was finally struck in Iraq and in
1928 a secret agreement called the
redline agreement with which is for the
first time reproduced on the inside
front cover of the book the redline
agreement created the world's wealthiest
and richest monopolies the French
through their government controlled oil
cartel called CFP now known as total to
British through anglo-persian and a
British form of shell and of course
anglo-persian is now British Petroleum
and the and the Americans through the
nearest Development Corporation which
was
by Standard Oil as a government
designated and regulated and an approved
representative of the American oil
industry took a map and because they
didn't know what names to put on these
maps because the countries are always
changing it just took a red line and
drew around the entire Middle East and
said we own all the oil in there and no
one can compete with us in this region
and we won't compete with each other in
this region this red line agreements the
genesis of this red line agreement and
the fallout from this red line agreement
which continued deep into the 50s this
red line agreement is the saga of our
involvement in Iraq and the Western oil
imperialistic involvement in Iraq it was
in fact a war of Western oil imperialism
against Arab and Islamic nationalism and
in the first decades of the 20th century
Western oil imperialism won and but by
the time it was between the wars the
interwar period the tide had changed and
now the Arabs have us over a barrel
literally the fact of the matter is
there will never be a military
disengagement in Iraq there can only be
in energy disengagement from Iraq as
soon as we get off of oil we will no
longer have a need to put ourselves to
put our intelligence services to put our
Democratic surrogates we can say
democracy from the Today Show to the
Tonight Show and when the Arabs hear the
word democracy they hear a code word for
we want your oil if the Arabs wanted
democracy they had a seven thousand year
head start on the United States they
don't need a permission slip from New
York they can develop it on their own
they're not of the Arabs of Mesopotamia
of Iraq are not a pluralistic people
they're not a tolerant people but the
fact of the matter is they have a right
to their own way of life we are over
there it is not sand
we crave in Iraq
it's oil and because we are there we are
now in a confrontation with this culture
sir yeah back to the Farr who were these
anti-jewish rioting mobs where they
specifically gangs that were organized
by the mufti and and Rashid Ali or do
you think they represented a more
spontaneous outbreak of anti-jewish
feeling Fonte Nia so were they organized
by Rashid Ali and the mufti well the
answer is they weren't organized
specifically by Rashid Ali in the mufti
because they and the Germans and the
German prava provocateurs had fled into
Iran by this time they were spontaneous
you have to understand that after years
of agitation against the Jews the
population there was so incredibly anti
British and so incredibly anti-jewish
that it didn't take much to spark them
you know they used to show the newsreels
of World War two and when Churchill's
picture came on everybody booed and when
Hitler's picture came on everybody
cheered
they used to have posters and the
posters said in heaven Allah is your
master on earth Adolf Hitler will rule
us and so consequently it was it was fun
it was spontaneous and eventually even
the police forces joined in another
question yes ma'am
the ideological aspects of Arab
nationalism and the ideological aspect
of militant Islam for example the role
the Muslim Brotherhood
their question is sort of where do you
see those fitting in because it almost
seems to me when I'm listening to you
like you're saying that Arab reaction is
what was viewing this whole thing a
reaction to an invasion rather than what
so was so creative all right the
question is did I not mention the innate
character of the of the Arab Jihad and
Mojave ISM and such things as that I
want you to understand that I've gone
back some 7,000 years and I've yet to
find a generation which was not visited
in Mesopotamia and and Iraq by
devastation and violence
there have been genocides and oppression
and destruction of human rights and mass
murders every generation going back
7,000 years as soon as Iraq was he
emerged into independence from the
League of Nations and signed the League
of Nations treaties to respect
minorities they went in and massacred
the Assyrians the Assyrians have been
massacred the Armenians have been
massacred the Sunnis have been massacred
the Shia have been massacred the there
is never enough violence to stop the
cycle of violence and the Arabs are very
good at victimizing their victimizers
and the reeve ICTA my zation the
constant victimization never stops there
and so it isn't our policies that have
really caused the problem that we see
today it's really our presence it isn't
how many school houses we repaint and
how many bridges we rebuild it's our
very presence not our policy that they
detest
and so when the Arabs had attempted to
create a national identity in 1920 and
when they were so thoroughly let down
they created this great
but now it isn't something that can be
fixed one two three we don't just get
off of oil and we're out of Iraq and
that's the end of it today it's a legacy
that can't be undone easily and so even
if we're out of iraq tomorrow morning
even if we Rada out of oil tomorrow
morning and there's a hydrogen car in
every garage we are still looking at a
legacy of world terrorism in the
schoolyards of russia in the train yards
of barcelona in the hotels of bali and
in the financial district of new york
another question yes I refuse that
survived the partnered yes I interviewed
some Jews who survived too far hood but
there are very few of them there are a
few in this room today you should know
that there are very very few competent
records kept of the far hood because it
was hushed up there were very poor
communications even the diplomatic
dispatches that I have are from many
days later I will I will say that I try
very hard not to rely upon oral
testimony and I prefer to rely upon
government reports Commission reports
there was a far wood Commission and it
did show that scores of Jews were killed
and hundreds of Jewish businesses were
burned and and this was an International
Commission and I fundamentally looked to
that yes cannot be stopped by the
Western world there's nothing we can do
or say that would turn it around that
would defuse it the question is is there
nothing that can be done to turn it
around and stop and defuse
the the international terrorism that
we're currently experiencing I wish that
there was I wish there was a button that
we could push I think we've all tried to
push such buttons in the past but there
is monumental violence in many parts of
the world yeah in Chechnya as I said in
Saudi Arabia itself in many lands in the
Philippines there is now a legacy of
hate and the only thing that would turn
it around it can't be turned around from
outside it can only be turned around
from within there needs to be a reform
amongst those elements that believe that
what they are doing is in God's name and
until that occurs and that will not
occur quickly until that occurs we are
going to have to live with the legacy of
night of July 24th of 1920 yes yes did
go beyond Baghdad did it spread to the
north on did it spread to the south and
I'm specifically interested in whether
introduce them well I would say that the
far hood was all over Iraq I believed
there was someone in the audience who
said that their family was in the Basra
that the Basra Jews remember Jews were
not just in Baghdad there's a picture of
the Jews of Kurdistan with her with
their Kirti had a headdress on in the
book so it was everywhere the reason I
focused on Baghdad is because that was
the worst part of it that was the part
that that that made history if you will
because it was a turning point and so
yes it did affect many and I'll take one
more question this challenge do you have
any recommendation to the Bush governor
yes
do I have a recommendation for the Bush
government well read the book because I
think if the Bush administration had
known about these facts we would not
have gone into Iraq as we did and I
would not have written this book I would
also advise the Bush administration not
that I'm one to advise them but I would
ask the Bush administration find some
polish people because there aren't any
polish people who don't know that the
Russians liberated Poland from the Nazis
the worst monsters of all time but they
stayed and then Russia became hated in
the hearts of every Polish person if in
fact we had gone in on Monday to
liberate the people from Saddam Hussein
and bed out on Thursday it might have
been a different matter but we have
stayed we have stayed far too long it
has gone to the top of our agenda
because of oil and only because of oil
and so consequently I would say look
back and see if we haven't used the same
terminology the same phrases the same
tactics and the same logistics thank you
very much ladies and gentlemen
and and and for those who have asked I
will be back in the spring of 2006 with
my next book the end of oil the final
chapter thank you